this to my wife GQ baby tennis I just
take one hopefully the only one tight yo
what's up this is wild language GQ and
these are my essentials this one is
tricky because this is the most often
stolen product I've been very known to
steal all my friends charges don't leave
home without it and he's gonna be
breaking - my journey had been over 50%
this one is for short Stover I'm sorry
to that friend whoever the charger it is
but you know the game is the game Mophie
charger this is the 2020 and beyond
dynamic duo
need both of these and it's the reason
why a lot of men wear personnel
because you can't really fit this in
your pocket but Mophie charlie
what's happened I probably make it like
- like - recharges and invites
recharging I mean my phone will be at
50% cuz I'm addicted to social media
I like tuned blast I blame Ryan Reynolds
for my teen blast addiction but this is
a safe place so I got thing I can open
up about it I'm I started playing tune
blast mode a year ago and I'm actually
ashamed about how much money I've spent
for power option seem glad to me I could
be your next pumpkin if mr unno's the
shooting dead before I had to start from
level one so that means I beat two
thousand five hundred and seventy two
levels if you to have a to blast
problems feel free to hit us up this
which is another thing you know I try to
keep them relationships separate you
know we're an open thing we ever open
relationships with each other but the
switch is like putting my ride-or-die
for real like when it's time to like put
my phone down I'll play a little Smash
Brothers
can I get a picture of the switch right
there yeah yeah it's green on both sides
I'll play Smash Brothers and I play
River City girls breaking cuz I have
like social anxiety and I'm not really
like always like on planet Earth yeah
and I spend a lot of time on airplanes
too so it's a quick fix
I'm one of the best boss ultimate smash
players in the world
I play Donkey Kong
I just started learning a badge on
because we snake I think I'm really the
best was nothing wrong and for my next
essential is everybody's essentials my
cell phone my best friend's my
girlfriend a manager a personal
assistant it enables me to play some
blast yeah I mean I think they'd affairs
now but you know I just no I just deal
with it like you know I didn't have an
Android for a while but then I started
to loving myself no but um might an
Android for a while just always felt
comfortable with two phones until I
didn't have two phones no more boy I
mean this is good because I'm fidgety
and I'm saying I like to like you know I
want a ton of postman's I've seen the
new razors and I think but you know you
know everybody has only nostalgia
goggles when it's they're cute I prefer
to bring the sidekick back out though
that do a sidekick right now but Brown
my talk just text me and we'll text I
might get a black bird no because the
real ones never that the BBM era was
crazy that was like the original like
Twitter like he'll say like bbm was that
was a great time I did I might go back
to black bear though because it's just a
lot more organized
nigo toothpicks you know um a lot of
Nigerians no no Nigerian men
specifically like our toothpicks doesn't
matter the brand you know using jollof
rice chicken move around just keep one
on you and then you know I like you know
Razor Ramon is one of my favorite
wrestlers and you know who used to have
to fill our time so just make me feel
that very room that's in sylheti it's
multi-purpose you know I like to think
it was multi-purpose but I said no Chico
Chico talking to the back guy and it's
mint you know you get that fresh feeling
saying it just make you feel like you
ready to hit the streets in New York or
find something some salt feet to talk to
[Music]
not a specific lotion per se but lotion
in general um
shea butter cocoa butter preferably
insane cuz they let my skin and growing
flourish those two full capabilities but
I'm the guy that keeps a little dose
from my mom so my hands is just looking
right along I don't want to forget where
I came from but you know I got places to
go from the lotion is essential first of
all Hotel lotion is not for black people
that's one thing everybody knows you put
it on you just can't be dry the next ten
seconds and the W is great because they
have the Bliss lotion and I think that's
finished it's absolutely fantastic it
smells like Venus
brothers books with dry skin black folks
W is good lotion I might be able to put
a little image of everyday but um I like
shea butter like cocoa butter and I like
an idiot
those are my three favorite floors get
orange on something like some bougie
[Music]
smells like a hotel it smells like a
nice hotel like the lobby of a nice
hotel I know very specific right but
that's what I thought
lotion another great essential very
essential musician but these are for
listening to podcasts nice it's the
funny thing about it is I like to keep
headphones on me I'm broke I have
regular headphones knowing apart sorry
keep losing I like to listen to other
things I like to listen I like talk
radio parks and stuff like that just to
take me out of music for a little bit
but I'll keep these two get away and
then I plug these into my switch when in
case nobody wants to hear like river
city girls screaming loud and kicking
and punching I get into my zone with my
total blast
ah listen to Jose doing some turns even
though I kind of try to stay away from
the music stuff but I listen to whatever
I could find sports you know I listen to
the Will Ferrell anchorman run a couple
times and then sometimes I'll just
browse Apple whatever I feel like
listening to yeah yeah I mean I got the
best album of the year so I listen to it
a lot for some reason I don't think I
listen to my music as much as other
artists let's say how many does that
make sense I mean these are the probably
the most honest ones because you know
that's why most people are gonna digest
music just didn't have phones like this
scrunchie headband whatever
tomato tomahto but normally I keep a
black one I didn't need one today book
and I think I've got the crown one today
this is just to get my hair on my face
and I don't even put it in a pretty
ponytail some time to the side to the
front just I don't feel like all these
these locks on my wood and I just you
know keep it on me sometime this
because I I stopped with this but what
he's it easy to lose track of so god get
him impacts it like 50 anything like
there wasn't like a pair of my jeans
probably had to use one of these five
for like past like seven years probably
a lady from harlem did my hair yesterday
before the show and you know I normally
get my hair down in DC LA New York or
Miami when it's fancy my wallet is
pretty interesting so this is a
Balenciaga wallet but you can barely
read the lines think it was silver at
one point shiny silver with red letters
and now it just looks like it's been in
the muffler for like like a month and as
character though I used to be a designer
while announces Yaga nectar all over it
I have a nando's black card which means
I can eat free Nando's whenever however
as much as I want for a long time
Nando's is essential the Nando's is
delicious this is really good um I can't
wait to go back the episode where
they're on every corner and I'm in
London
um I had a Dave & Buster's car to here
but there's not only no more while it
always an essential
I want to say this is essential what I
knew I was gonna go come see some fly
individuals today so I just said I can
show it on this morning sometimes you
know I just like to throw some diamonds
on sometimes I love anymore
like I take a more humble approach which
is not just trying felt loved me and I
just felt like I want it on today why
not work tomorrow my question for the
most part good style is essential but
nowadays when I go to the airport man
the first more things I put on as long
as I have a hoodie in some shades I just
wear but one of my regular day-to-day
being flies essentially I got this Jason
to Beverly Hills it wasn't cheap you
gotta cheat yourself sometimes I forgot
where I got these but a lot of people
don't know this but I don't I don't have
no fulfilling in these three fingers so
I don't really switch my earrings that
much you know and it's difficult to like
I need help taking things on and off
though but I keep I keep my everything
going oh I got a purse when I go my
daughter got her his peers she was early
on she was only like a couple months old
when she got him but I saw her like I
was like okay let me see what they're
about to do to my child oh I got it
first
oh really I mean I was I was it hurt me
just to see her cry when they when they
did it she got her almost cry for her
the album was essential wow that's crazy
very very essential wow that's crazy
that's essential a lot of people call
that a healing out or growth I'm saying
and that's that's important that's
essential to everybody's wellness you
know
[Music]